hello I'm Jonathan Werth from the
connected Academy talking pictures
critical engagement with visual
storytelling is brought to you in
association with the World Press Photo
Foundation today we're going to talk
about a project that documents the
families of people who are missing
people who have been forcibly
disappeared during a civil war that
lasted over extended period of time is
why we asked you to think about how you
might go about telling the story of
something that isn't there in
preparation for this session you'll hear
from a photographer and journalist who
spent multiple years making an oral
history and visual document of people
who've lost family members to a war in
the Middle East that began over 40 years
ago and probably thousands of miles away
from where you are now you might well
question what the relevance of that is
to you but there are themes common to
all storytelling and so what we have
here is a particular case study where in
a lot of these themes crop up so as a
way to think about some of those themes
and make them into jumping-off points
for us to discuss in a connected notes
let me ask you what are the different
vulnerabilities that you hear in this
conversation with whom do the duties of
care lie what are the responsibilities
of both the photographer and the
photographed and as audience what are
our responsibilities and finally do
images function as evidence it sounds
like an obvious one but ask yourselves
again do images function as evidence and
how do images and their meaning change
over time so let me describe it again
differently with those questions as a
frame you're about to listen to a female
lebanese photographer who only ever knew
war growing up she became a photo editor
but bounced out to the effects of
looking at an unending stream of images
of war and its effects on her own people
you'll hear how she made peace with
photography again and then when the war
ended in a journalist left their work
done she began to make her body of work
it's a series of portraits of the people
like herself who were left behind there
are three things I find particularly
fascinating about this conversation what
is it that she's making her approach to
making it and thirdly what will it come
to mean
each of her subjects is kind of an
archivist in a way carefully shepherding
the evidence of their loved ones those
scant everyday belongings of the people
who didn't come back a toothpaste tube a
pack of cigarettes poster each one a
touchstone to the past and providing
another testament to their loved one and
the old age of these people reminds us
that one can imagine a time not so far
from now after the cigarettes have
disintegrated and the houses have been
cleared when all that will remain of
these people's stories will be dahlias
project the missing and you've got
Benjamin Chesterton a male English X
radio producer who doesn't speak Arabic
and who has to produce two different
versions of her project for radio and
web audiences over a very short space of
time with all is inherent technical
difficulties and you're going to hear
from the people whose stories they're
both trying to tell and just what that
process was like and is like for them to
go through don't forget to share your
notes in the platform comment on other
people's notes take time to pause
reflect review sections go back through
the stuff you're not sure about dig
around in those networked class notes
that's where the real value is in the
conversation not the content and try be
supportive of the people who can't get
into a room with other learners
merhaba my name is Elias amici and I'm a
stalker for a base in Beirut Lebanon
since 2010 I've been working on the
estimated 17,000 missing and forcibly
disappeared from the 1975 to 1990 11e
Civil War the victims were from
different political and religious
backgrounds they came from all parts of
Lebanon and they were of all ages the
kidnappers did not just when she ate
between men or women at that time but
the missing was not exactly the first
project I did on the aftermath of wars
that I lived in the summer of 2006 I
witnessed the terrible Israeli
aggression on lebanon as i was working
for their social distress and its office
in ladies as a conservative
a year later I went to the south of
Lebanon the area that suffered the most
during the 2064 and it was heavily
bombarded I had seen those images during
the 2006 war but I had not seen them to
my eyes since then that day I had my
camera with me
I entered homes that were destroyed and
abandoned what really shocked me was how
much the private homes of people had to
come public anyone could enter that
because there were no more doors anymore
and obviously no more inhabitants on the
floors lay clothes of those who lived
there sometimes photograph belongings
keys even though there were no people to
photograph I said that those houses told
the stories of their owners those spaces
reminded me of how much my life turned
into public during the war
I have no personal life back down my
private one would like that as a photo
editor my phone was ranking constantly
starting as early as 5 or 60 and
sometimes at 10 hours after midnight my
computer screen was full of messages
from everybody requesting photographs
from all ApS offices like all over the
world
I had to stare at photographs on the
computer screen and readings for 34 days
images of the injured the dead the
destruction people crying the death of
their loved ones
heartbreaking photographs of people I
related to the war had forcibly turned
my life from private to a public one the
same as for those faces
so I took photographs of few houses and
I then formed a series of photographs
that I tried to abandon spaces I only
shot that over few days but I felt it
was my way of reconciling with
photography after that project I started
working on the Lebanese issues
especially those related to women right
until I decided to start researching the
subject of the missing
sorry McGee see professor of English and
comparative literature at the University
of California Los Angeles the Lebanese
civil war began in 1975 and ended in
1990 it was a war over the distribution
of power among and between different
sectarian groups in the country or
really more specifically the
distribution of power among the elites
of different sectarian groups the
principal axis of tension in the war was
between those who wanted to maintain the
older system of Maronite hegemony the
privileged Maronite Catholic elites and
those who wanted to make the political
system more representative of and
accountable to the population of the
entire country so although it's often
depicted as a religious war or war over
religion or even a war between religious
communities or sects it really was a
struggle over the distribution of power
despite this fighting and displacements
of population did often blend into
tensions between different sectarian
communities and at times degenerated
into blind inter-communal violence on
top of the killed and injured there were
thousands of kidnappings it took place
during the war the kidnappings were
often done on the basis of one's
communal or religious identity because
Lebanese identity documents officially
list your religion if you're caught by
the wrong kind of party and you have the
wrong kind of idea you could be in
trouble and that happened to a lot of
people during the war the kidnappings
were sometimes for ransom
sometimes for murder sometimes for
execution and torture sometimes for
reprisal sometimes revenge and sometimes
for personal vendettas so it's not clear
necessarily why somebody's kidnapped
very often people would disappear and
that would be that nobody would know
what happens to them everybody knows
somebody who was kidnapped I personally
know a neighbor of ours who was
kidnapped and then held for a few days
and then released I have a relative who
was kidnapped and released I think the
same day
and one of my closest childhood friends
was kidnapped with his parents and never
heard from again and of course there's a
big difference between killed and
wounded and those who had disappeared
because killed or wounded I mean awful
is that is of course for the people
themselves and for their families and
friends and so forth at least you know
what happened whereas people who dis
disappear you don't know what happens to
them so there's no closure there's no
resolution to the trauma it's important
to point out that those responsible for
the kidnappings for the most part remain
very close to power in Lebanon given the
country's amnesty law right after the
war they've been absolved of guilt and
responsibility fates of those that
disappeared in the war has never been
resolved and certainly nobody's been
held accountable for the crimes they
committed during the war so basically
during the war of 2006 many
international photographers and
journalists came to Lebanon to cover the
events the country was full of foreign
press the war lasted for 34 days and the
pressure is doing a superb work like a
super work covering the direct events
the bombardment tires something I could
have never done when the ceasefire was
agreed on in August 14 the media kept
documenting the direct aftermath for a
few weeks before the country was empty
again and the people who were left
behind were left to suffer with their
own new realities that was my case to
all the international photographers had
left they all had them months off to
rest but I was the one who had to stay
behind and the country that was this
word was the one I lived in it was like
the horror never ended this is the same
case for the Civil War and all the wars
conflict trashes that happened since I
was born the media leaves in those ends
so through my photographs I try to tell
the stories of people who are left
behind those who stories do not
perfectly interest the mainstream media
the issue of the missing and kidnapped
haven't been covered much shaky so in my
project I wanted to dig deeper in the
story
I met Ida and Leda Jada at the chance
during a gathering for Odette's Allen
who was killed when a car hit her but
that was the mother of two young men and
his sister her son and her daughter were
kidnapped in the 80s the families were
all devastated it was yet another mother
who had died before receiving any
information on the fate of her children
[Music]
the Day of Ashura has just allowed us to
visited at home for few minutes as I
went from one room to another her home
looked as if it was untouched for
decades inside her daughter's closet
hang a life-size poster of a male model
on the bottom of the closet next to shoe
boxes lay some old dolls and on the wall
was hanging a black-and-white poster of
the Eagles those are items that people
throw away daily while they have no
value for us they act as one of the main
evidence for the one signed presence of
the missing person the photographs of
the belonging gave much more depth to
the project
three years later in 2012
I called Gina - after as she and her
mother would allow me to take their
photographs and tell their story
not as a massager year on average
reserved Vegas
maava Christmas medallion on aphasia
metal Namas help now that's an amenity
mom I said no fish evoke asthma all a
motto spell misogynist would Lana penis
direct oral the scoop but my daddy a
llama of mahathma take the Fadden what
Americans need this mean Hellena know
half a bottle it's a machine but then no
mythical norm up there what I Drive had
an honest man Almohad and she so happy
little bad antics Ahava busy macabre
antics are hard to be clear these antics
have him you keep the bonnet ran through
the school that they do with mannequin
behind as the happy third landlord
easements enemies and the fact has a
semi and no hospital facebook and now
let's go for EMP on a wall cetera with
lollipop Arden
Littleton official still o Muhammad
oxide indoctrinate naharana and of Tears
knowledgeable Jared colonics robust
through my photographs I try to tell the
stories of people who are left behind
those who stories did not specifically
interest the mainstream media the issue
of the missing and kidnap haven't been
covered much shaky so in my project I
wanted to dig deeper in the story - to
learn more about the different
narratives behind the missing and the
kidnapped at the beginning I
photographed for trade for example of
the families then I learned about the
belongings they kept of the victims with
each family a different story the same
pain of course but a different story and
details
after a month or two I got in touch with
Benjamin Chesterton from dark rabbit we
email back and forth and he was
interested in my way of photography I
told him about the project of the
missing and she was later decided to
come to Beirut and work with me on that
project for the BBC for three days
Benjamin and I met mothers of victims of
enforced disappearances
we met with NGO people MP X militia
members women telling about the last
time they saw their children their
husbands they talked about their
continuous struggle and their only wish
to know the fate of their loved ones
mostly indicated with the families were
conducted in their mother tongue and
obviously Dalia would conduct those
interviews and I would assess with
really helping her to shape them in in a
sense in that situations its hardest for
her because she's got to bring a
stranger into a situation is very
painful for those women and if you read
the interviews that she conducted with
them for this project they talked about
each time how the wind is opened up and
that is an extremely difficult thing for
anybody to do repeatedly in front of
journalists or anyone
[Music]
hi does husband command was kidnapped in
1985 along with his nephew come on as
they were coming back from their work
they never heard of them again so along
with a man the mother of my friend
I visited them at home either refused to
be photographed even after a man
interested I looked for the best place
to take the photograph of Lena there
were two chairs that were placed on each
side of a small table and on the wall
behind them a painting was hanging high
that brought a framed portrait of her
husband from the 80s and placed it on
the table along with his fight another
Moglia so one below one another man
Judith Judith Kemal - well the mckameys
most is our sewage gabon a hospital
illusion we can imbibe as no command ok
me have deduction the conception written
by a stubborn stubborn
as I move the sofa facing the two teeth
and stood behind it to have more space
in distance either suddenly sat on the
seat and told me to take the photograph
[Music]
we were all shocked a man Lina and
myself
she had resisted being photographed for
over an hour while we were having tea
earlier so I just clicked through frames
and then her daughter said for the
portrait after her instance what I love
about it there's a huge amount of
respect that is not trying she's not
trying too hard and it's it's subtle and
it's poetic
so he talked about the idea beautifully
she does and it's a beautiful images of
all the limits
so anyway when I developed the films and
scan them I can't hide a photograph to
the jedis by email both of them thought
that the photograph looked very empty a
man and her daughter on the other side
thought it was beautiful and represented
her situation and the emptiness in her
life I explained by email also that this
was exactly what I was aiming at the
empty chair that was supposed to be
occupied by the husband had she not been
kidnapped instead a photograph of him
from the 80s sitting on the table at
this time Falls for him after he was
kidnapped in the photograph he's smiling
when life was better for the family and
by coincidence he was looking at his
wife Ida who has aged and was looking at
me with sad eyes thirty years after his
kidnapping hazard in Mumbai in Britain
no mafia hiya Tiana's Chiquita surah
Baqarah Garces Kamala
Jambu Anna Ardin hmm
Ambika labelled chimera a sticky and no
message it is norm mama Cupid only me
Sofia heal yourself our day with angina
Mahalo ha black Ibaraki I don't have a
the foolish utterance of all at AMARG
Shimin a Dakar Senegal mother Oh
Michelle now hide father coming
and no en esta la basura de nostradame
interlaken mr. DeLaughter
hello national pavilions countess unlock
the suitable portray their data so it is
given my own people cousin is nominal
make a link in the National Harlem
occasion and this is the surah I can
mushaira which I had a mammal very
beautiful things I've had enough
especially face up in bed then we also
what is amazing army lots of them learn
quicker there's nothing to be petted
there that is a strength and a defiance
and an anger mixed with a little bit of
hope that each day is getting spot down
[Music]
so it's always like a privilege and a
pleasure to be in such a place as a
welcome guest very much as a welcome
guest but professionally you're thinking
what do I need and really that's welcome
and that trust it's only worth it for
them if you do a good job if you tell
their story properly it's only worth the
pain that they have to go through when
they open themselves up if you meet that
with a professionalism and a
determination to get it right victors
were had a deist of the stream of two
hands and wash up rather than Julius and
I see for example give us a meticulous
team at a salon is a ridiculous
amendment amongst socialism another kind
of is what happens what goes up a fluid
somewhat oh love Yummie and you job you
Thomas ball your doll conceal a solar
nebula perfect I believe that taking the
time to get to know people going back
again and again and again and showing
that you care about them and their
problem and that we're not only here to
photograph them and leave but that we
are really trying to make a change and
then their cause has become ours this
makes people open up and trust us and
let us into their life the families tell
the stories of the missing loved ones
they show their belongings that they had
guarded for decades they share all the
skills and evidence they had collected
throughout the years I had understood
the value of those belongings and
photographed them as precious relics
each item alone I was thinking about
what I wanted to say particularly in
relation to you as the audience looking
at though
and how you might respond to that
phrasing and the thing that I wanted to
tell you was that the danger of the
photo is that it holds someone in time
in moment it kind of says this is this
is it right and life is not like that
because it's much more complex and
sometimes we need earlier to have sat
down with the women and just hear what
they think and it kind of takes away a
lot of the formality of what you're
seeing and your feelings about what
you're seeing in fact what I would say
is her interview with the women in many
ways is actually more humanizing than
the photograph itself and that's
something really interesting to reflect
on thank you everyone
there are lesson to it not only within
the stories contained the missing but
there are lessons for us on how visual
storytelling is done what those dynamics
are in that process and pointers to how
we can become more sophisticated as both
media producers and media consumers
there is a tension in photography and
there always has been an uneven
distribution of power unnecessary
vulnerability the basic premise is the
same Photography enables us to see the
world through the eyes and the lens of
someone else and there's an intimacy in
that but when a person brings a camera
or a smartphone up to their eye they
there is immediately the photographer
and the photographed and there will be
the audience or the viewer at some point
and the most powerful stakeholder in
those three-way relationships is almost
never the subject the subject has to
agree to be vulnerable and not just once
not just at the point of the shutter
release that photograph may never be
seen within the context that it was
actually taken the chances are it will
live on in many different contexts even
simultaneously and its meaning might
well shift with each audience and each
time the subject will be vulnerable
again is why these class interviews are
set up the way they are between a
photographer a subject and the audience
it's to explore that tension and then is
for us to reflect on our relationships
with the world when we bring the camera
to our eye and make the world our
object and listening to dahlias
conversation one of the first things
that's apparent is that telling someone
else's story is a speculative endeavor
I mean Darla and Benjamin asked
permission of their subjects in the full
knowledge that they might well and do
sometimes say no darling the talks of
people agreeing to have their
photographs made years after she's first
asked them and we begin to get a sense
of the negotiation that takes place
between the subject and the photographer
and the importance of the trust in that
relationship I've said in the
introduction that what dahlias work will
come to mean is interesting but that
applies to all our images it is
difficult if not impossible for us to
know what our images will come to me in
future contexts what their values might
be and to whom which is problematic when
we've negotiated or built a trust
relationship with our subjects what did
we promise what is their understanding
what exactly did they give their consent
for have we been transparent and honest
about what we can and can't promise
because when the subject appears as an
image they're going to stand alone and
we can't possibly predict what the many
possible feedback loops consequences for
that subject might be we all have a
right to carry a camera but does that
automatically confer the right to
photograph other people and if so then
it's interesting to consider what the
circumstances might be where we would
feel justified in doing so if say it
made the subject feel uncomfortable
distressed or scared to go to the very
edge of where we feel uncomfortable
about dealing with that as photographers
this is the thing that I love about
dahlias work we don't know where it will
lead but we know it's built on a
foundation of her asking those tough
questions on a subject by subject basis
exposing her own limitations and
vulnerabilities and we know that each
image is a testament to that rigour and
integrity it means that with each new
layer of the evolving project from
places to artifacts to portraits all all
testimonies to face book and to an
Instagram feed the project grows as more
and more people buy into the process the
Dahlia has set out so now is the time
here in this session for you to put down
your own moral markers to take a
metacognitive view to step back and look
at your own practice from a distance and
to spell out your best practice your
code of ethics you can also now access
the deep dive materials including the
extended interviews and our interview
with World Press Photo winner Rena
Efendi
in that she reflects on all five of the
courses key questions with reference to
her work and in particular two examples
where she's telling the stories of
things that are no longer there once
again don't forget to dig around in the
class notes investigate the hotspots see
why particular parts of the conversation
of being responded to and by whom reach
out and connect with people and support
those who can't get into a room full of
fellow students once you've had your
fill of that revisit your four corners
image and don't forget to submit it in
time for it to be included in our
webinar review
I'm Jonathan Wirth and you can connect
with me via Twitter at Jonathan
underscore Worth hopefully I'm floating
around right now in the Twittersphere as
you listen to this thanks very much